Traduttore: Federico MINELLE
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Alexa, SIRI, Crystal,
la segretaria Amy,
e questa segnatevela:
la robottina lavavetri Heidi,
in arrivo dal Giappone.
Tutti questi sono esempi
di Intelligenza Artificiale,
la tecnologia più pervasiva
dei prossimi 20 anni.
Ma c'è un'altra cosa
che questi esempi hanno in comune:
hanno tutti volti e fattezze femminili!
Nell'immaginario collettivo,
i robot sono sempre stati
un'allegoria delle classi sfruttate.
Anche la parola robot deriva
da un termine ceco, che significa schiavo.
Noi viviamo in un mondo
dove 600 milioni di donne vivono
ancora sotto la soglia della povertà.
Una su cinque è stata vittima di violenza.
Per dare un'idea,
se ce ne sono 1.000 sono in questa sala,
significa 200 donne.
Prima che io abbia finito di parlare,
dieci donne (dieci!) nel mondo
moriranno di quello che dovrebbe essere
il momento più gioioso della loro vita,
ovvero il parto.
Mentre assisto all'avanzata
di robot femminili
che lavano le nostre case,
organizzano le nostre agende,
e si prendono cura di noi
con una voce gentile,
e senza lamentarsi mai,
non posso che rabbrividire
quando penso a questi parallelismi.
Anche Microsoft si è cimentata
nella sfida dell'Intelligenza Artificiale
lanciando TAI,
un bot con le fattezze
di un'adolescente gentile,
progettata per interagire
con gli utenti di Twitter.
Dopo poche ore dal suo lancio,
TAI è stata subissata
di commenti sessisti,
che ha a sua volta ripetuto
esponenzialmente in rete.
E prima di venire chiusa,
solo 16 ore dopo il suo lancio,
TAI aveva imparato ad apprezzare Hitler!
Ma come ha fatto TAI ad imparare?
Come funziona l'Intelligenza Artificiale?
È molto più semplice
di quello che possiamo pensare,
e dovrebbe interessarci tutti.
Per capirlo insieme,
facciamo un esperimento:
che cosa vedete in questa foto?
Il Colosseo. E in questa?
Fin qui tutto semplice, direte voi.
In effetti stiamo parlando
di un oggetto simbolo,
non solo di Roma, ma dell'umanità tutta,
che rimane invariato
- e per fortuna, almeno quello
è uguale a se stesso -
da qualche migliaio di anni.
Anche da un punto di vista geometrico,
il Colosseo è piuttosto riconoscibile:
ha delle righe verticali,
degli archi, un ovale ...
Nella prima fase dell'AI, i ricercatori
hanno in effetti fatto questo:
[hanno] cercato
di insegnare all'algoritmo
a riconoscere una serie di forme geometriche.
Ma che dire allora di questa immagine?
Per noi è ancora facile riconoscerla.
ma per un algoritmo,
si tratta di aggiungere
forme totalmente nuove
e un punto di vista totalmente nuovo.
Cosa succederebbe se il Colosseo
fosse pieno di gente?
O se lo riprendessimo
da un'altra angolazione?
Capite che è estremamente difficile
insegnare a una macchina a pensare,
con questo metodo.
Solo otto anni fa, Fei-Fei Li,
una ricercatrice considerata
massima esperta di computer vision,
la scienza che insegna
ai computer a vedere,
ha avuto una intuizione semplice
ma rivoluzionaria,
ed è questa:
nessuno insegna a un bambino a vedere.
Nessuno insegna a un bambino a vedere?!
Che banalità è mai questa!
Prima che vi alziate dalle vostre sedie,
vi voglio dire che non è così scontato,
e che sulla base di questa osservazione
impariamo molto
di come noi stessi apprendiamo,
così come del modo
in cui apprendono le macchine.
Se i nostri occhi fossero
un paio di fotocamere digitali,
essi scatterebbero una foto
ogni 200 millesecondi:
il tempo medio di un battito di ciglia.
Quando siamo alti così.
quando abbiamo 3 anni,
abbiamo già immagazzinato
milioni di immagini.
Tutte queste vanno a costituire
una sorta di enciclopedia digitale,
sulla quale basiamo
il nostro apprendimento.
Per questo si è pensato
che anziché costruire algoritmi migliori
era sufficiente dare alle macchine
dati sempre più fitti
e di sempre maggior qualità,
mimando un po'
l'apprendimento dei bambini.
Ecco perché Google è così felice
di ospitare gratuitamente
le foto delle nostre vacanze
e dei nostri viaggi,
o i nostri documenti di lavoro.
Hanno bisogno dei nostri dati,
dei nostri dolci, succulenti dati,
per alimentare la loro intelligenza.
In effetti, nel machine learning,
avere dati migliori
è sempre più preferibile
che costruire algoritmi migliori.
Ma adesso facciamo un altro passo avanti
e per questo vi chiedo
di prendere i vostri cellulari.
(Sorriso e Risatine)
Avete controllato le e-mail? Bene!
Adesso andiamo tutti insieme
su un motore di ricerca per immagini.
Quello che preferite.
E scriviamo "CEO", la parola inglese,
ma ormai di uso internazionale,
che denota il numero uno di un'azienda.
Che cosa vedete?
Ho sentito qualcuno dire "uomini"!
Per le prime 50 o 100 immagini
vedete maschi bianchi.
(Applausi e Brusio)
Qualcuno tra di voi
riesce a vedere un CEO donna?
Barbie!
Qualcuno vede una CEO donna nera?
Uno, là in fondo!
Qualcuno vede un CEO disabile,
una persona in carrozzina?
Nessuno?
Il pregiudizio non è una cosa nuova,
non lo abbiamo inventato noi oggi.
Quello che è nuovo,
e che si sta creando oggi,
è la magnitudine
che quel pregiudizio assume
grazie all'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Funziona più o meno così:
se pensate all'esempio del bambino,
è facile capire
che le macchine hanno già disponibilità
di molti più dati
di quelli che vediamo noi
e li apprendono molto più velocemente.
La maniera in cui funzionano è questa:
la macchina apprende;
diventa più intelligente;
poi apprende ancora;
poi diventa più intelligente.
E avanti, come in un ottovolante
che a ogni giro aumenta la sua velocità.
La rivoluzione
dell'apprendimento automatico
è molto diversa
dalla Rivoluzione Industriale,
perchè questa non si assesterà,
sarà sempre più veloce:
È qualcosa che non abbiamo mai visto,
simile a quello che il matematico Good
teorizzava come
"esplosione dell'intelligenza".
Ma che intelligenza sarà?
Che tipo di intelligenza vogliamo che sia?
Come poniamo le basi giuste
perché l'Intelligenza Artificiale ci aiuti
e ci liberi dalle diverse opportunità
dovute a etnia, genere o ricchezza?
Sono domande difficili,
ma dobbiamo far modo
che diventino sempre più parte
delle nostre conversazioni.
Non possiamo chiudere gli occhi
e lasciare che a occuparsene
siano solo gli esperti,
perché qui siamo chiamati a determinare
come vogliamo che vengano programmate
le intelligenze del futuro.
E in ultima analisi,
in quale tipo di società vogliamo vivere.
Quando parliamo di un'Intelligenza
Artificiale superintelligente,
che migliora se stessa,
la nostra unica opportunità
è di darle la giusta diversità di visione
e la giusta varietà dentro il set
di dati da cui apprende.
Lasciate che vi racconti
una storia personale.
Nel 2005 mi sono laureata
in ingegneria biomedica,
e la mia tesi di laurea
era un dispositivo indossabile
per prevenire la caduta negli anziani,
il fattore primario
che induce a ridotta mobilità
e quindi all'indebolimento e alla morte.
Per realizzarla,
avevo costruito un sistema elettronico
di 3 accelerometri triassiali
collegati ad una maglietta della salute.
Gli accelerometri trasmettevano
i loro dati di posizione,
e io andavo a integrarli
in un algoritmo
di previsione della caduta.
Ho coinvolto tutti i miei
compagni di corso,
che vedete sotto
durante la lezione
e poi a ringraziamento per avermi aiutata.
Tutti erano chiamati a simulare
le più svariate cadute:
chi camminando sul tapis roulant,
chi inciampando,
chi fingendo di svenire,
chi cadendo dalle scale.
Sono stati lunghi mesi di lavoro.
A 15 giorni dalla consegna
degli elaborati, niente:
ancora l'algoritmo non andava!
Poi una sera, me lo ricordo
come se fosse ieri, Bingo!
L'algoritmo aveva cominciato a prendere
e riusciva a prevedere
la caduta prima del'impatto,
con una buona accuratezza,
e soprattutto si migliorava mano a mano
che lo alimentavo con nuovi dati.
È abbastanza imbarazzante
ammetterlo adesso,
di fronte a 2.000 persone
e a tutti quelli
che ci guardano in streaming,
ma adesso so che avevo costruito
un ottimo strumento
per la prevenzione delle cadute,
ma solo degli uomini!
In effetti, avevo utilizzato
i miei compagni di corso.
Sarebbe funzionato altrettanto bene
se avessi preso delle donne?
Se avessi avuto varietà
nel mio set di dati?
Non ne sono così sicura.
Comunque mi sono laureata
e poi ho cominciato a cercare lavoro.
Non sorprendentemente,
il profilo di ingegnere biomedico
specializzato in cadute
non era primo nei motori di ricerca.
E... lo sapete?
Nemmeno il profilo di ingegnera
è primo nei motori di ricerca.
Le ricercatrici
della Carnegie Mellon Univesity
hanno effettuato uno studio
sui lavori ad alto reddito
pubblicati online:
se una donna riceve in media
300 visualizzazioni per questi annunci,
un uomo ne riceve 1.800.
Questa cosa potrebbe essere
una colpa delle aziende,
che usano come target, per i lavori
ad alto redddito, solo gli uomini.
Ma la discrepanza è così ampia
che viene più facile pensare
a un algoritmo deviato
e che alimenta se stesso!
E adesso vi chiedo:
siamo davvero disposti [ad accettare]
che a decidere il lavoro
che andrà a fare la nostra bambina
sia un algoritmo che la discrimina
perché il suo genere non è rappresentato
nelle stanze in cui viene costruito?
Davvero quello che vogliamo
è che le cadute dei nonni
siano più prevedibili,
e che quindi i nonni vengano curati
prima e meglio delle nonne?
Se ammettiamo
che l'elaborazione delle informazioni
è la fonte delle opportunità,
allora dobbiamo anche pensare
che solo portando più varietà
all'interno delle comunità
che programmano l'Intelligenza Artificiale,
avremmo una tecnologia più giusta
e una società più equa.
Ma la varietà da sola non basta:
vi racconto un'altra storia personale.
La mia amica Chiara,
una donna eccezionale,
si è fatta strada in un ambiente
estremamente competitivo,
diventando la numero uno
della sua azienda.
Ma Chiara è una persona sensibile,
e ha conosciuto momenti duri,
come quelli dovuti alla depressione.
Promuovere una persona come Chiara,
senza guardare al suo genere
o alla sua provenienza,
appare sicuramente giusto,
e credo sia condivisibile
usare un algoritmo per farlo:
quale maniera migliore di levare
soggettività a questa decisione?
Esiste una azienda americana
che è in grado di desumere
qualsiasi cosa su di noi,
usando le nostre briciole digitali:
le informazioni che lasciamo sparse
in rete, senza nemmeno accorgercene.
In particolare,
sono in grado di predire la depressione
mesi prima - mesi prima! -
che insorga qualsiasi sintomo.
Naturalmente, il loro intento
è quello di intercettare il malessere
quando è ancora piccolo, appena curabile.
Ma adesso vi chedo
di pensare un attimo a Chiara.
Quali sarebbero le implicazioni
morali e sociali
se lasciassimo che a decidere
fosse un algoritmo
che pensa a noi
dalle nostre briciole digitali,
da quello che facciamo
su Facebook, su Twitter, sulla rete?
Solo con una comunità
scientifica più inclusiva,
e rappresentativa di tutti i generi
e di tutte le minoranze,
riusciremo a mantenere un controllo etico
sull'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Ma attenzione!
Gli algoritmi non devono essere una scusa
per abdicare alla nostra
responsabilità personale,
bensì una opportunità
per costruire una intelligenza collettiva,
planetaria, inclusiva e partecipata.
Grazie.
(Applausi)